[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد عززت وفاه
المنشد العام بالانابه لتنظيم الاخوان
ابراهيم منير في نوفمبر الماضي من الصراع
الداخلي على السلطه حيث لا يزال اسم
المرشد الجديد الجماعه غائبا في انعكاس
واضح
لهشاشه التنظيم وخلافته الداخليه المتقدمه
الجهتان المعنيتين باختيار القائم بعمل
مرشد الاخوان هما اللجنه الاداريه ومجلس
الشورى لكن ابراهيم منير كان قد اوصى
باختيار قائما باعمال المرشد من غير اعضاء
اللجنه الاداريه العليا او حتى مجلس
الشورى الاخوان رجل من خارج دائره الصراع
الموجود بين كل من محمد البحيري ومحيي
الدين زايد وحلمي الجزار ووقع الاختيار
على صلاح عبد الحق الذي يعمل طبيبا ليكون
قائما بالاعمال حين اتخاذ القرار النهائي
بشانه الا انه هو وفقه محللين يمتلك
شخصيتها لا تتمتع باي حصه يدي وليست لديه
اي او ليس لديه اي مشروع فكري عدا عن انه
لن يكون قدرا على حسب اي خلاف داخل
التنظيم
[موسيقى]
ونحيي ضيوفي لمناقشه هذا الموضوع من عمان
محمود الخرابشه وزير الدوله لشؤون
القانونيه السابقه اهلا بك من القاهره
منير اديب بحث في شؤون الحركه المتطرفه
والارهاب الدولي اهلا بكم
اسم حالي ان ابدا من القاهره معك يا سيد
منير سيد منير مبدايا لنضع الموضوع في
اطاره لما نتحدث عن التعذر ترشيح مرشد
لجماعه الاخوان هل نتحدث فقط عن مجموعه
ابراهيم منير ان نتحدث عن لانه صارت
انقسامات صرنا نتحدث عن مجموعه منير
مجموعه محمود حسين ومجموعه الداخل كذلك
فعما نتحدث بالتحديد واين تكمن الصعوبه
نعم اهلا وسهلا بك يا استاذ اديم
وبضيفك الكريم وبشاهدي العربيه نحن عندما
نتحدث عن حركه الاخوان المسلمين نحن نتحدث
ليس عن جماعه واحده وانما عن عده الجماعات
او عن جماعه بثلاثه رؤوس نحن نتحدث عن
جبهه لندن التي كان يقودها القائم باعمال
المرشد ابراهيم منير والذي وفاته المنيه
قبل شهر ونصف من الان ونتحدث ايضا عن جبهه
اخرى هي ترى ان هي الممثل الرئيسي للاخوان
المسلمين وهي موجوده في اسطنبول
واعلنت هذه الجبهه تولي محمود حسين قائما
باعمال مرشد الاخوان واستند وفق مقاله هذه
الجبهه الى نص الماده الخامسه من اللائحه
الداخليه للاخوان التي ترى انه في حال
وجود عذر من تولي المرشد له شؤون التنظيم
يتولى نائبه حتى يتولى اكبر اعضاء مكتب
الارشاد سنا وهو يرى انه عضو مكتب الارشاد
الوحيد خارج السجون وبالتالي من حقه ان
يتولى اا يعني افصل فاقول نحن نتحدث عن
ثلاث جبهات كل جابها ترى انها الممثل
الرئيسي لاخوان بما ان ابراهيم منير توفى
كانت الانذار تتجه الى ثلاثه اسماء محي
الدين الرايت ومحمد البحيري وهناك اسم
ثالث هو حلم الجزار على اعتبار انه ممثل
له الشباب الا ان الجميع تفاجا بان
ابراهيم منير تركيه هذه الوصيه سمى فيها
من يرى هو انه هو الاقدر
هذه الجبهه ربما نعم صلاح عبد الحق لانه
يرى ان التنظيم يمر بانشقاقات وهذه
الانشقاقات قد تحدث داخل الجبهه نفسها
جبهه ابراهيم منير بمعنى هناك ثلاث جبهات
لكن هذا الانشقاق قد يحدث وهذا هي وجهه
نظر ابراهيم منير قبل ان يتوفى قد يحدث
داخل الجبهه التي كان يقوله
محمود همم صحيح حول هذا الانشقاق وحول هذه
الصراعات المنتظره كما قراتها استاذ محمود
هل بوصيه همم ابراهيم منير همم
يتلاشى هذا الصراع ستلاش هذه القسمات او
بالعكس هي ستضع هذه الانقسامات على طويله
هذه الحركه وبطريقه اعنف يقول الباص
يعني الحقيقه واضح تماما ان هذه
الانقسامات ستتصاعد وان الوصيه التي تركها
ابراهيم منير لن تحسم الخلاف والجدل خاصه
كما اشار الزميل العزيز ان هنالك ثلاث
جبهات واضحه بثلاث قيادات والاهم من ذلك
نحن نعلم ان هنالك حال الصراع داخلي بين
صفوف الاخوان في من يتولى موقع المسؤوليه
والسلطه لاداره شؤون الجماعه ونعلم ايضا
ان هنالك انشقاقات وصراعات داخليه تدور
دائما خاصه ان النظام الداخلي او اللائحه
الداخليه التي تنظم عمل الجماعه لم يتم
اللجوء اليها ولم يتم تفعيلها وبالتالي
وجود هذه القيادات الثلاث همم
همم سيؤجج الصراع فيما بينها واعتقد انه
لو كان هنا كانكانيه لحسم هذا النزاع لحسن
باعتبار ان المرحوم ابراهيم منير قد توفى
منذ اكثر من شهر تقريبا او اكثر همم لا
اكثر مده طويله من سنه ال 21 وبالتالي هذا
يعني انه لم يعد هنالك امكانيه لحسم هذا
الامر من خلال وصيه ابراهيم منير بل ان
حالي من الصراع الداخلي التي تجري بين هذه
القيادات الثلاث في سبيل الوصول للمرشد
العام او المراقب العام لجماعه الاخوان
المسلمين وان نحن نعلم ان جبهه لندن وجبه
اسطنبول وجبه داخل ايضا اي مصر لها نفود
ولها تاثير على الرغم ان جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين لم يعد نفوذها كما كان سابقا
ونعلم انها تنتشر في كثير من دول العالم
حيث ان هنالك بعض الاحصائيات التي تقول
بانها تتواجد باكثر من 86 الى 100 دوله
على امتداد العالم خاصه اذا انها حركه
قديمه وهنالك الكثير من من يختبئ او يتغطى
بثوب غير ثوبها باعتبار ان هنالك بعض
الجمعيات وهناك ايضا بعض التنظيمات
الدعويه او بعض الاحزاب وهي تمارس مهام
وعمل جماعه الاخوان لكن هذا الامر طبعا
بالنتيجه اعتقد سيتم حسمه وطالما ان اكبر
الاعضاء سنا الموجود في في اسطنبول قد
اعلن انه سيتولى همم رئاسه او او المرشد
العام للاخوان للجماعه الاخوان المسلمين
هذا يعني انه سيبقى هنالك حالي من الصراع
بين القيادات في من يتولى همم
هو هو المفروض السيد منير كان العمل لجنه
اداريه عليا او لمجلس همم مشهوره كانت
المفروض كان لهم مهمه اختيار المرشد ولكن
ان تكون هناك وصيه الموضوع في حظ ذاته
اللي لم يعمل به في ما قبل في ما يخص حركه
الاخوان من عاهد قطب البنا الى اليوم هل
يمس هذا من شكل الحركه هل يمس من تماسك
الحركه في حضارتها هل بدنا نتحدث عن شكل
جديد مجزء جزيئات اخوانيه وليس حركه كامله
نعم همم
اعتقد ان ذلك هو دليل على حاله الانقسام
التي تعيشها الجماعه والتشظي الذي تعرضت
له والذي ربما يشكك فيه البعض ما يحدث
داخل ال ال الاخوان او تنظيم الاخوان الان
هو انهيار كامل وانا عندما اتحدث عن اتحدث
عن انهيار التنظيم ما دلت الفكره تحتاج
الى جهود للمواجه هذا الانهيار الكامل جزء
منه ان قيادات التنظيم السابقه كانت تعلم
وتدرك ان عمليات الانهيار التي تحدث
للتنظيم قويه ومتسارعه ولذلك اراد الراحل
ابراهيم منير ان يوقف هذا الانقسام ويوقف
هذا التصدي وان يقف امام الاختلاف الذي
سوف يحدث بعد وفاته ولذلك لجى الى هذه
الوصيه ومن قبل فجاه المؤسس الاول للاخوان
حسن البنا
قبل وفاته الى تسميه من ياتي خلفه وقد سمى
من قبل المستشار حسن الغضيبي وكان مستشارا
بمحكمه النقض في القاهره وقد اتو به من
غير مكتب الارشاد وقد تولى بالفعل همم
زمام التنظيم ربما على مدار سنوات كامله
اراد ابراهيم منير ان يقلد المؤسس الاول
حسن البنا همم ربما في اختيار القائم
باعمال مرشد الاخوان فضلا على ان هناك
صفات كانت تجمع ابراهيم منير وتجمع صلاح
عبد الحق لعل الشخصين كان متهمين في قضيه
همم اطلق عليه بتنظيم 1965 وهؤلاء كانوا
متهمون مع سيد قطب في نفس هذه القضيه فضلا
على ان صلاح حق من صفاته شخصيه انه شخص
هذه الطباعه يجمع ولا يفرق وليس له اي
خبرات اداريه او تنظيميه ولا همم وبالتالي
لن يدخل في عمليات خلاف وانما سوف يجمع
وفق ما كان يرى ابراهيم منير صفوف التنظيم
ولكن في اعتقاله وفي تقديري ان ذلك سوف
يؤدي الى مديد من الاختلافات داخل التنظيم
وان الانتقاق الذي حدث في التنظيم سوف
يحدث في جبهه ابراهيم منير نفسها و سوف
يتهاوى الخلاف الكبير الى خلاف ربما صغير
داخل الجبهات المتناحره
استاذ محمود بانه من الغريب ان تشهد حركه
كحركه الاخوان هذه الانشقاقات في الواقع
المستمره منذ فتره والتي تتعمق شيئا فشيئا
لمعروف عن الحركه انها حركه جدا منظمه
والمعروف عن اعضاءها بانهم موطيعون فان
تكون هناك حركه تمرد وتمرد يعني مصر كره
ثلج يكبر شيء فشيئ حتى بدنا نتحدث عن ثلاث
جبهات وهذا الموضوع مش من شهر او من اثنين
لم يتمكن احد من ايجاد نقاط التقاء بين
الجبهات الثلاث كيف يفسر ذلك
العزيز همم انه لم يتم اللجوء الى النظام
الذي يحكم عمليه اختيار المرشد العام
لجماعه الاخوان المسلمين او كيفيه اختياره
باعتبار انه تم تجاوز همم مجلس الشورى وتم
تجاوز ايضا اللجنه الاداريه وهي الجهتين
المعنيتين في ان في ان يتم اللجوء اليهما
لكي يتم اختيار او تعيين
المرشد العام الان الامور واضحه تماما
واعتقد صحيح ان التنظيم كان متماسكا
وهنالك قدره على الاستمرار باعتبار ان هذا
التنظيم تنظيم قديم ومن التنظيمات التي
تمكنت عبر مراحل زمنيه طويله ان همم يعبر
هذه الصعوبات والتحديات وان يحافظ على
قدره على الاستمرار لكنني اقول الان ان
هنالك الكثير من النظرات السلبيه تجاه هذا
التنظيم
الخلاف الذي حصل من خلال قيام ابراهيم
المنير بتعيين نائبه
لكي يقوم باعمال المرشد العام دون اللجوء
الى اللجنه الاداري ودون اللجوء ايضا الى
مجلس الشورى هذا يؤكد انه كان يدرك عمق
الازمه التي كانت تعصف بجماعه الاخوان
المسلمين من الداخل وكان يدرك ايضا بانه
لا يمكن ان يتم الاتفاق على شخص يسمى من
قبل ال ال الجبهات الثلاث المتنافره سواء
كانت لندن او اسطنبول او الداخل في مصر
ايضا وبالتالي همم لا اعتقد انه سيتم حسم
هذا الموضوع من خلال همم ما يحكم همم
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين ومن خلال اللجنه
الاداريه او مجلس الشورى وهذا سيس ان
الخلاف سيتعد وسيستمر وقد يؤدي الى مزيد
من الانقسام
والتفكك في الجماعه خاصه ان كل من هذه
الاطراف لا زال حتى الان متمسكا بموقفه
دون ان يكون هنالك ان يتنازلات ودون ان
يكون هنالك ايه في صلاه في ما بينها على
الاقل لحسم الخلافات والوصول الى وجهه نظر
مشتركه تمكن من اختيار او من الاتفاق على
شخص المرشد العام لجماعه الاخوان المسلمين
همم استاذ منير ما الذي تغير حتى يفقد هذا
التنظيم تماسك ما الذي تغير داخل التنظيم
الذي هل هو تاريخ الذي تغير هل هي المرحله
تغيرت هل هي ظروف تفجرت يعني شهدت حركه
الاخوان اختلافات او خلافات ولكن ان تصل
الى هكذا انقصمات طويله حتى انقسامات همم
قبل كانت تحل همم
بطرق مختلفه بالحوار او حتى بالعنف ولكن
ان يمتدئ الخلاف طويلا ما الذي تغير ما
الذي حدث
نعم يعني عندما نجيب على هذا السؤال الذكي
لابد ان استحضر امرين اولا ان عوامل
الانهيار داخل التنظيم هي عوامل انهيار
داخليه وهذا لابد ان نضعه في الحسبان هناك
خلافات واختلافات ربما على تولي السلطه
وايضا على اداره شؤون التنظيم فضلا على ان
هناك جزء من هذه الخلافات له علاقه
بالاموال التي يسيطر عليها محمود حسين
والتي اراد الراحل ابراهيم منير ان ياخذها
منه وان تضم الى خزينه التنظيم الذي كان
يديره ابراهيم منير في هذا التوقيت هذا
فيما يتعلق به عوامل انهيار الداخليه ايضا
هناك عوامل انهيار كان سببها هو همم
استراتيجيات مواجهه التنظيم التي تقودها
دول كثيره لان التنظيم بيت خطرا ليس فقط
على امن هذه الدول وانما على الاسلام الذي
رفعوا التنظيم شعارا في اوقات كثيره
واعتقد منذ العام 2011 وحتى هذه اللحظه
شعرك كثير من الدول ان هذا التنظيم هو ضد
مفهوم الدوله الوطنيه والقوميه وبالتالي
وضعت استراتيجيات كثيره كان جزء من هذه
الاستراتيجيات ان انهار التنظيم بهذه
الصوره ولكن هذا الانهيار لن يؤدي الى
اختفاء التنظيم همم حتى تظهر استراتيجيات
اخرى لها علاقه بتفكيك الافكار المؤسسه
لهذا التنظيم بمعنى ان الانهيار الداخلي
قد يؤثر على التنظيم ولكن هذا التنض- هذا
الانهيار سوف يكون مرهونا باستراتيجيات
اخرى لها علاقه بتفكيك الافكار المؤسسه
للتنظيم واعتقد ان كثير من الباحثين
والمراهقين
والمراكز البحثيه تعمل على هذه
المنطقه وفي هذه المساحه واعتقد ان
الموضوع في متابعه هذا الموضوع بتداعياته
وتطوراته شكرا جزيلا على المشاركه من عمان
محمود الخرابشه وزير الدوله لشؤون
القانونيه السابق ومن القاهره منير اديب
باحث في شؤون الحركه المتطرفه والارهاب
الدولي شكرا لكم